WANTED TO ASK MORE QUESTIONS BUT
IT DIDN'T GO AS PLANNED.
HERE'S HER REPORT.
>> IF YOU THINK FOR ONE MINUTE
THAT THOSE POLITICAL ELITES
ACTUALLY GOT THAT VACCINATION,
YOU ARE SMOKING METH IN YOUR
MAMA'S BASEMENT.
>> Reporter: PASTOR GREG LOCK
HAS GROWN HIS AUDIENCE OVER THE
LAST YEAR BY CALLING COVID-19 A
FAKE PANDEMIC AND THE VACCINE A
SCAM.
>> I AIN'T GETTING NO SHEEP SHOT
IN MY ARM, I DON'T CARE WHAT
BIDEN AND THE REST OF THAT FAKE
FRAUD ADMINISTRATION SAYS.
>> I LOST MY UNCLE OVER THE
CHURCH.
>> Reporter: HOW?
>> PART OF IT WAS BECAUSE I WAS
SO VOCAL WITH MY IMMEDIATE
FAMILY ABOUT WHAT I FELT AND THE
SPIRIT I DETECTED FROM GREG THAT
I DIDN'T FEEL WAS ANYTHING
GODLY.
>> Reporter: CHIP DAVIS AND HIS
BROTHER, BILLY, ARE SINGER
SONGWRITERS OUTSIDE NASHVILLE.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THEIR FAMILY
HAVE ATTENDED LOCK'S CHURCH,
INCLUDING THEIR UNCLE WHO DIED
OF COVID-19 IN APRIL 2021.
>> HE GOT SICK WITH COVID.
HE DECIDED HE WOULD WAIT A
COUPLE OF DAYS BEFORE HE WENT
FOR HELP.
AND THOSE COUPLE OF DAYS WERE
PROBABLY CRITICAL TO WHETHER HE
WAS GOING TO SURVIVE COVID OR
NOT.
>> Reporter: DID YOU GO TO YOUR
UNCLE'S FUNERAL?
>> I DID NOT GO TO MY UNCLE'S
FUNERAL.
>> Reporter: WHY NOT?
>> THAT WOULD HAVE INVOLVED
PUTTING MYSELF IN THE PRESENCE
OF GREG LOCK AND A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE THAT I DON'T THINK ARE
THINKING PROPERLY RIGHT NOW.
>> I AIN'T PROMOTING IT AND I
DISCOURAGE EVERYBODY UNDER THIS
TENT TO GET IT BECAUSE I'M
TELLING YOU, IF YOU THINK THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET HEALTHY OVER
A VACCINE THAT'S SUPPOSED TO DO
AWAY WITH A VIRUS THAT HAS A
99.9% SURVIVAL RATE YOU'VE BEEN
WATCHING TOO MUCH FOX NEWS AND
CNN AT THE SAME TIME.
SO NO, LOOK, I HAVE NOT CHANGED
MY STANCE.
I HAVEN'T SOFTENED MY STANCE.
I HAVE STRENGTHENED MY STANCE
AGAINST THE VACCINE.
IT IS NOT FDA APPROVED.
>> I'VE GOT TO TAKE A XANAX.
I'M SERIOUS.
MY PULSE IS OUT THE ROOF RIGHT
NOW.
>> CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN WHY?
>> THE ONLY WAY HE COULD HAVE
BEEN PROVEN WRONG IS MAYBE IF MY
UNCLE HAD TAKEN THE VACCINATION.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE A
VACCINATION, THAT'S ENTIRELY UP
TO YOU, BUT TO SPREAD
MISINFORMATION ABOUT IT IS DEAD
WRONG AND IT COULD POTENTIALLY
LEAD TO MORE LOSS OF LIFE.
>> Reporter: WE INTERVIEWED LOCK
IN DECEMBER 2020 WHEN MORE THAN
4900 TENNESSEEANS HAD ALREADY
DIED OF COVID-19.
>> THERE'S NO PANDEMIC.
COVID-19 IS NOT A PANDEMIC.
>> Reporter: WHAT IS A PANDEMIC
THEN?
>> NOT WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING.
I'M 44 YEARS OLD.
WE'VE NOT HAD ONE IN MY LIFETIME
SO I DON'T KNOW AND THIS IS NOT
IT.
>> Reporter: HE OFTEN TALKS
ABOUT THAT WITH SIGNIFICANT
EMBELLISHMENT.
>> CNN SHOWED UP AND SAID WE'D
LIKE TO KNOW WHY YOU ARE SO
ARROGANT.
WHY WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO KILL
EVERY ELDERLY PERSON WITHIN 250
MILES OF NASHVILLE.
WE AIN'T KILLED NOBODY YET, BY
THE WAY.
>> Reporter: WE WENT BACK TO
LOCK'S CHURCH ON SUNDAY AND WERE
SET TO INTERVIEW HIM THE NEXT
DAY BUT HE CANCELLED ON US AFTER
WE ARRIVED AND HIS PUBLICIST
SAID HE DIDN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
DOING IT.
HE DID NOT RESPOND TO OUR
QUESTIONS VIA EMAIL BUT LATER
THAT DAY HE POSTED A VIDEO TO
FACEBOOK.
>> WE ALMOST HAD TO CALL THE
POLICE ON CNN, ON THREE CHICKS
FROM CNN.
WE TRIED TO BE SUPER NICE, THE
WHOLE DEAL.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SAY WE'RE
KILLING PEOPLE, WE'VE HAD A
COVID OUTBREAK.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO RUN ME OUT OF
CHURCH WITH A WHIP, YOU BETTER
BE A FULL GROWN MAN, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, IS WHAT I'M TELLING
YOU.
THESE CHICKS DIABOLICAL.
>> THERE CAN BE NO JUSTICE FOR
MY UNCLE.
HE'S GONE.
IF GREG WOULD FIND A MODICUM OF
HUMILITY AND JUST SAY I WAS
WRONG.
MASKS HAVE SAVED LIVES, IT'S
BEEN PROVEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN
AND NOT BE BELLIGERENT.
>> Reporter: IN DECEMBER LOCK
ALSO TOLD US THIS.
>> PEOPLE CAN CALL US CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS OR WHAT THEY WANT TO,
BUT THERE ARE ABORTED FETAL
TISSUE WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF ALL
OF THESE VACCINES.
>> Reporter: SEVERAL PEOPLE AT
HIS CHURCH TOLD US THE SAME
THING.
THOUGH FETAL CELL LINES WERE
USED TO DEVELOP THE VACCINES,
THEY DO NOT CONTAIN ANY FETAL
TISSUE.
THEN IN FEBRUARY CHIP'S UNCLE
COBURN SAID IN A FAMILY GROUP
CHAT THAT HE WOULDN'T GET THE
VACCINE BECAUSE IT HAD FETAL
TISSUE IN IT.
HE DIED TWO MONTHS LATER.
>> THIS IS A FAMILY ROOM CHAT.
HE SAID THERE'S STUFF IN THIS
VACCINE SUCH AS ABORTED FETUSES.
AS FOR ME I'LL DO AS I HAVE FOM,
MANY YEARS, I'LL PUT MY TRUST IN
MY ALMIGHTY GOD.
EACH OF YOU DO WHAT YOU FEEL.
LOVE MY FAMILY.
>> Reporter: HOW DID YOU FEEL
HEARING YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS
PARROT THE THINGS THAT GREG LOCK
HAD SAID ABOUT COVID THAT
WEREN'T TRUE?
>> IT MADE ME ANGRY.
>> Reporter: AND THEN SEE THEM
GET SICK FROM IT.
>> IT MADE ME VERY ANGRY.
>> Reporter: EVEN AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED TO COBURN, SOME MEMBERS
OF THE FAMILY STILL DON'T WANT
TO GET THE VACCINE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS?
>> WHAT DO I THINK ABOUT IT?
>> MM-HMM.
>> IT'S DANGEROUS, BUT SOMETIMES
IT'S POPULATION CONTROL.
>> YEAH?
>> JUST LIKE ABORTION.
>> Reporter: CHIP AND BILLY TOLD
US THEY FELT LIKE IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THAT POLITICS HAD
MADE MORE TENSION IN YOUR
FAMILY.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S TRUE?
>> THEY THINK ME AND THE OTHERS
ARE STUPID.
>> Reporter: I DON'T THINK
THAT'S TRUE.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> WELL, BECAUSE OF THEIR VIEWS
AND THEY CAN'T WE BELIEVE THE
WAY WE BELIEVE.
♪ I'M JUST WAITIN
>> I'M ACTUALLY SHOCKED THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO EVEN GET TOGETHER
TONIGHT.
>> THIS IS WHAT GREG LOCK AND
THAT TYPE OF CULTISH RELIGION
HAS ROBBED ME OF I FEEL LIKE.
TIME WITH MY UNCLE BECAUSE THIS
IS VERY RARE.
♪ I'M JUST WAITING ON T